the MIT Museum studio and Compton
gallery is the experimental arm of the
MIT Museum it's driven by student ideas
student energy the studio is a
completely open space a lot of people
come in and they're wondering is this a
classroom is the laboratory can I do
research here what's really going on and
I think it's actually a blend of all
those things and the whole point of it
is to not fit into one of these kind of
predetermined categories and it's really
the only space on campus where students
can pioneer their own creative vision on
a project on an experiment or anything
else we want people out there to
understand what makes this place tick
and one of the key things that makes MIT
tick is our students and at MIT there
are tons of creative people artistic
people but there's not always
opportunity I guess so to get away and
and work on a creative project and so
for me the studio was amazing because I
had the chance to put aside my other
work and go and make something with my
hands and be creative and be artistic
it's really freeform if you want to have
a more formal Europe experience they do
that here if you want to simply have
access to the space work on some small
things and give back to this community
as well that's open to you in addition
to being a work space it's also a
gallery so it's a place where we can
show off all the cool projects that go
on here if you think of the MIT Museum
it's like a multidisciplinary learning
environment I mean it's full sensory
visual sound Interactive's environmental
exhibitions and learning experiences and
so we thought why wouldn't we engage
students with this so MIT Museum studio
is an incubator space where students can
come and build displays some of which we
hope will go in the museum for visitors
to see I think it's easy for people to
isolate themselves into a certain niche
of work or academia but what's unique
about this space is that it forces you
to break down those barriers in those
walls and consider things that you
wouldn't normally consider in a
traditional kind of academic setting
like how something looks how something
feels the MIT Museum studio and Compton
gallery makes student creativity and
learning processes visible I would like
to see the studio become a showcase
right at the center of campus of that
kind of student exploration and student
expression
you